MIHA: Hello everyone.
Welcome to another session
of Google Payments Live.
My name is Miha [? Ionesco. ?]
PAUL: And I'm Paul
[? Mying. ?]
MIHA: And today we have
a special guest.
SUDHIR: I'm Sudhir [INAUDIBLE]
and I'm the
PM on the risk team.
MIHA: And the topic for today's
an overview of the
Google Payments risk engine and
automatic fraud detection
techniques.
I know a lot of you had
questions about cancelled
orders and Google's techniques
for detecting fraud, so we
thought it would be a great idea
to bring in Sudhir for a
panel discussion around
those issues.
So let's start throwing
questions at Sudhir.
PAUL: Yeah.
And the risk team is the team
that I ask for all of my--
Whenever one of you guys
asks us, we always
defer to the risk team.
So they should know pretty much
everything about risk.
SUDHIR: We are the best.
PAUL: And just to get
it kicked off.
We have a risk engine, but can
you tell us what problems the
risk engine solves?
SUDHIR: So the risk engine is
our fraud management solution
for Google products.
This is a completely in house
built technology.
And we use it to solve almost
all the payment fraud
problems, including account
takeover, stolen instrument,
daily abuse, any of those
kinds of things.
Analyzes some of the policy
abuse problem
on AdWord side mostly.
So this is a comprehensive
solution that we use for all
risk issues.
PAUL: Got it.
And can you get into how
it works at all?
SUDHIR: Sure.
It's a machine learning
technology that we use.
And we use it because we
want it to be adaptive.
As most of us know, fraudsters
are very adaptive.
And so we have to use a solution
that also adapts very
quickly to the new
fraud patterns.
And we use lots and lots of
signals, hundreds of them,
based on the transaction
data that we collect.
And then we try to use that to
learn the fraud patterns.
And try to then flag
the accounts
that need to be reviewed.
PAUL: Good.
Can you get into any detail
about which signals you
specifically use?
Or provide more information for
merchants to see what they
should be doing on their
side to improve.
SUDHIR: So it's hard for us to
talk about signals because for
any risk system to be really
effective, we don't want our
fraudsters to know the signals
that we are actually using.
But just to tell you, we use a
lot of common signals that
many risk systems use like
IP and things like that.
But we also have some
proprietary signals that we
use in our system to make
it much more effective.
PAUL: OK.
Got you.
MIHA: So Sudhir, what products
leverage the risk engine?
SUDHIR: So pretty much all
products at Google that either
collect money or disburse
money go
through the risk engine.
So all paid products.
That includes Google AdWords.
It includes Google Wallet,
Android, Enterprise.
So any products where there's
money that's being exchanged
between us and the merchant
or the consumer.
MIHA: So lots of products.
So how can we handle
all these products?
At what scale does the
risk engine run?
SUDHIR: So yeah, Google
definitely has lots of
transactions going on.
And risk engine works also in
real time, which means that we
have to handle all these
transactions in real time.
Which means that we are
scaling to hundreds of
transactions per second
at times.
And risk engine does very,
very well with that.
MIHA: So that's real time.
So how fast is that versus
manual review?
SUDHIR: So there
is actually two
component of the risk checks.
There is an automated portion,
which actually we
do it in real time.
So as the transactions are
coming through, it goes
through the system and we
actually check and escort the
transaction.
Based on the where the score
comes in, we will sometimes
send it for manual review.
And the manual review of course
is not real time.
It takes its own time.
But again that also happens
fairly rapidly so that we can
actually come back with the
decision in our system.
PAUL: So I guess this goes
into our next question.
And I think this is one of the
questions that a lot of
developers are asking.
Why are orders cancelled?
Why are some orders cancelled?
Or why are a lot of
orders cancelled?
SUDHIR: Sure.
We wish all orders
could go through.
But the thing is, almost any
product that you have there is
going to be fraudsters
who would want to do
something with it.
And there is a chargeback that
comes if the fraudsters
actually use something.
And then the card owner or
payment instrument owner
reports it.
And then they actually will
process something which
basically is called
chargeback.
Most card association do not
want the fraud to actually go
at a very high level.
And so they have a limit, either
1%, 2%, depending on
where you are and which
association
you are dealing with.
At which point, the card
association will start
imposing fines.
And if it happens for a very,
very long time, they might
even cancel your ability
to accept
payments using those cards.
And so for us to not get into
that scenario, and not have
our developers get to that
scenario, we have to decline
some orders.
We have to cancel some orders.
Just to make sure that the
fraud is under check.
PAUL: Makes sense.
All right.
What are some causes
of the frauds?
SUDHIR: I mentioned
this before.
So their frauds can be many,
many different ways.
We can have stolen instrument
fraud, which is the normal
fraud that happens across
many, many merchants.
We also have account takeover.
So you can actually take
over somebody's
Google Wallet account.
And then start making
payment using that.
And so that is another fraud.
One fraud that we see a lot in
digital transactions on the
mobile phone a lot is what we
call friendly or family fraud.
And this is a different kind of
fraud where somebody in the
household might be using the
owner's payment instrument to
make payments with or without
the knowledge of the owner.
And so what happens is that a
lot of risk signals that we
collect on the transaction look
very similar because it's
the same household.
It's the same IP.
Same device in many cases.
And so it might be slightly
harder to catch.
But that fraud actually
happens quite a bit,
particularly in the digital
transactions.
A lot in app ways as well.
PAUL: OK.
It's not Google canceling orders
all the time, right?
There's other third-parties that
are sometimes involved?
SUDHIR: That's right.
So everybody who's involved in
the transaction, from the
association, the banks that
issue cards or carrier billing
where the carrier are involved,
everybody in the
ecosystem wants to keep
the fraud under check.
And everybody wants to
participate in doing some
control to make sure that the
fraud doesn't actually go
really, really high.
And so banks often will
do declines based on
signals that they have.
Because they want to make sure
that their cards are not being
used illegally or without the
knowledge of their customer.
Same thing with the
carrier billing.
They have their controls where
they might have a per
transaction limit.
Like you can't transact anything
more than $10 using
their billing.
Or they might have a limit per
month, like you can't spend
more than $100 on that.
And so a lot of those people
also have the control.
Therefore if they decline the
transaction, then Google can't
process that at all.
And so we need to make sure that
they first approve it and
then we can do our risk check
and then we can approve that.
PAUL: Got it.
So every order has
to pass through
multiple levels of risk--
SUDHIR: That's right.
That's right.
It's a collaborative way to
reduce fraud in general, yes.
PAUL: Can you talk about what
other providers are doing or
other payment providers are
doing at all versus
how we handle it?
SUDHIR: Sure.
So most payment products have
their risk solution and they a
very similar kind of thing.
Sometimes the philosophy
is different.
What we have done consistently
is that we want to starve the
fraudsters from getting
the product they want.
So we would want to make sure
that they're not successful in
going through with the order and
getting the goods, either
digital goods or even
physical goods.
And so we prefer to cancel the
order upfront, rather than
allow the transaction to go
through and then do refunds.
Which some other providers, some
of the merchants do to
also counteract the
chargeback limit.
But in our philosophy, we think
that if you let the
fraudsters get the goods then
they will keep trying.
Because they are successful and
they'll just keep getting
the benefit of the thing.
So we try to catch early and
prevent the whole transaction
from going through in
the first place.
PAUL: Got it.
MIHA: Looks like you have your
work cut out for you.
SUDHIR: Yes.
PAUL: One last question.
So we hear that merchants are
encountering these order
cancellations all the time.
Are we doing anything to improve
that, to reduce the
amount of order cancellations
in our system?
SUDHIR: Yeah, sure.
So we definitely are doing
lots of things.
As I said before, we are
constantly looking for
signals, looking for new data
elements that we can use to
catch the fraud early.
One of the things that we are
doing for friendly fraud,
which is something that is
fairly new to us because we
didn't do all of this until
in-app transactions before,
what we're trying to do is
create a risk-based challenge.
We're hoping that somebody in
the household who's using the
device without the knowledge
of the owner of the device
would not know the password
for the transaction.
And so we would actually ask
for password in cases where
our risk systems believe that
this device is being used by
somebody without the permission
of the owner.
We went that route because we
want to keep the transaction
flowing smoothly in the
majority of the cases.
Some folks have decided to ask
for a password or some kind of
authorization for every
transaction
on the mobile device.
We have taken the route that
we want to make sure these
transactions flow smoothly for
the majority of the cases
where there doesn't seem to
be any risky behavior.
But in a very small set of
transactions where we suspect
that there's something different
going on, we would
want to prevent that by asking
for password or other
challenges.
And then if the person passes
that, we will complete the
transaction.
Otherwise, we won't.
And so what we're hoping is
that, today since we don't
have that challenge, we are
cancelling those orders
because we suspect it
and we cancel it.
By allowing the user to complete
the challenge and
going through, we would
let the legitimate
transactions go through.
And only prevent the ones that
actually are really, really
risky and are fraudulent.
That also will, we're hoping,
will have impact in how many
declines we get from banks and
other places because our fraud
overall is going to go down.
And that will actually
hopefully help.
So we're doing much better
on those things.
And as I said, we constantly
look for more and more ways to
detect fraud and let the good
customers go through.
PAUL: So two more questions
from me about this.
First one, is this going to be
on both Android and Google
Wallet for digital goods?
Or is this going to
be a specific
platform that you're doing?
SUDHIR: So yes, we are going
to be doing for all
transactions on the
Wallet platform.
But it is going to be in
experimental mode for a while.
So we're going to start
sometime in the
next couple of weeks.
And we'll start doing small
experiments making sure that
we don't mess up the
auto-processing and people's
experience with their device.
But this is going to be across
all platforms, yes.
PAUL: Got it.
That was actually my second
question about when are you
guys going to launch.
SUDHIR: So it is going to start,
as I said, more for
experimental way in the next few
weeks and then hopefully
we'll launch soon after that.
PAUL: Cool.
Cool.
MIHA: Looks like we're
doing a better job
on detecting problems.
So any idea, any estimates, on
how much fraud we prevented,
how much money we saved?
SUDHIR: Well, we constantly
are looking for ways to
measure that.
It's a little bit hard.
And so what I'll give you is the
way that we look at what
fraud system does for Google.
They're really three different
cost buckets we look at.
We look at the fraud loss,
which is a number that's
slightly easier to measure.
Because we want to make sure
that the overall fraud loss
and fraud in the
system is low.
The second bucket, which is
slightly harder to measure but
we are actually extremely
careful about that, is impact
on the good customer.
Because you can always prevent
fraud by cancelling all the
transactions and all good
customers will not go through
the system as well.
And so we are very sensitive
of that.
And we try to measure that as
much as possible, which is as
we call a false positive
in our system.
And we try to reduce
that overall.
And we balance that against
the fraud loss.
And then the third cost, which
is the entire operational cost
for the risk system.
Both from the development of the
technology point of view,
but also in terms of
the manual review
that we talked about.
And Google is, again, very,
very concerned about not
making that a very,
very big cost.
Because it's not just a cost
in terms of resources and
money, but it's also a cost
in terms of delay
in the overall system.
And so we try to make as many
augmented decisions as we can.
And have very small operational
costs to that.
And so in combine all these
three different things we need
to minimize across
all three costs.
And I think, conservatively,
we have saved millions of
dollars in the last few years.
MIHA: And I'm sure fraudsters
and fraud schemes are getting
more and more creative,
forcing us to
stay one step ahead.
What would be some of the most
craziest frauds you've seen?
SUDHIR: So let me tell you
something that actually
happened quite a while ago
because it's already addressed
across all the systems
so we're not giving
fraudsters new ideas.
So what happens sometimes
is what we call a
merchant-buyer collision.
Where an app developer or
fraudster will develop an app,
post it, sell it for $20.
But then have him or his staff
buy it from their own.
And then make money that way.
This happens quite a bit.
But what really happened a
couple of years ago is that
these fraudsters figured out
that they actually can walk
into stores and use
the demo devices.
So the phone sitting in the
store and they'll start
purchasing from there
their own app.
And so all of these phones
were connected
to the carrier billing.
And so they were using carrier
billing to pay and then
collect the money and
then walk way.
And then keep going
to different
stores in the same city.
Luckily, now not only that we
have prevention for that, but
also most stores do
not allow you to
purchase from those devices.
PAUL: This is giving me ideas.
MIHA: OK.
Let's not give more ideas.
SUDHIR: Let's get on the
bike and start riding.
MIHA: Great.
So what's next on the horizon
for the fraud investigation?
SUDHIR: So risk team
is always busy.
We have our work.
The majority of work happens
in reactive mode.
Both in terms of new fraud
patterns, people trying new
things and trying to figure out
any loophole that we have
in our system.
And so that makes us work
in that direction.
Also, we or our developer
partners start
launching new products.
And some of them are more
risky than others.
And so again, we work on
them reactively to
control those fraud.
But then also we have a lot of
work in the proactive side.
Where we are constantly looking
for new signals.
We are trying to make
our models better.
We are trying to make our
models learn faster.
And all those things happen.
So we keep a balance of reactive
and proactive.
And there is no dearth
of work to be done.
MIHA: Yeah.
Yeah.
Great.
Well, thank you very
much Sudhir.
SUDHIR: Thank you.
MIHA: And everyone I hope you
enjoyed our panel discussion
and we're looking for
more questions.
You can submit them
on the group or
for our future sessions.
And let's move on
and take some of
the submitted questions.
PAUL: Yeah.
Can you stay with us?
SUDHIR: Yeah.
PAUL: In case we get any
questions about risk.
MIHA: So let's see.
Let's go to our moderator group
and see what questions
have been submitted.
PAUL: I think the first.
I have it up here.
And I have the first
one for you.
It's probably for you.
Is VAT automatically collected
in EU countries?
MIHA: So we've been
getting this
question quite a few times.
Taxes are always an
interesting topic.
And the merchant is responsible
to collect taxes.
Either with talking about Google
Checkout or in-app
statements.
The case is the merchant
is responsible for tax
collection.
But it's very easy to specify
taxes, rates for various
countries and various
jurisdiction.
Just go to the Merchant Center
and under the settings tab
there is a tax account link,
which gives you a variety of
choices on how to specify
tax rates for
country or for zip code.
And once you do that, taxes are
automatically collected
and submitted by Google
to the developer.
And from that point on, it is
your responsibility how to
submit the taxes to the
tax authorities.
PAUL: And then the second
question, what countries do
you offer in-app payments?
And what I've done is I've
already pulled up the page
where we list the countries.
We'll list the international
countries where we support
in-app payments.
And I'll just share that list
with you right now.
So it's under our Developers
Guide FAQ.
As you can see it here,
it's developers.googl
e.com/in_app_payments/faq.
And we're just describing where
you can use this API.
And something like 18 countries
right now from
Australia down to the
United Kingdom.
We don't list the US here, but
we're going to add it.
And it's pretty intuitive that
Google and Wallet for digital
goods supports the US.
MIHA: So it's 18
countries now.
We're looking to add more?
PAUL: Yeah.
MIHA: And of course, buyers,
anyone who has a Google Wallet
account can buy.
And right now it's over 140
countries that are supported.
PAUL: Yeah.
MIHA: So literally anyone
can buy from merchant.
PAUL: Very international.
All right.
Let's get to the
third question.
MIHA: Next question.
So this is somewhat on topic
with today's fraud and risk
discussion.
The question is, orders from
my Wallet customers are
failing with the following
message, Google
cancelled this order.
Reason, took too long
to deliver.
We usually see this mostly
on Androids, I believe.
And usually I believe this
occurs when the account has
been flagged by the risk engine
for manual review.
So you'll continue to get this
type of error until the manual
review completes.
Anything you can add Sudhir?
SUDHIR: So yes.
On the digital transactions,
because we cannot have the
user wait for our decision,
manual decision, to be made,
we choose where we let the
automated risk engine to make
the decision.
And then if it cannot make a
decision and decides to send
for manual interview,
we cancel the order.
And we do the manual reviews
too but that is used for
future transactions and not for
the current transaction.
Because we don't want the user
to keep waiting for 5 to 10
hours or whatever it takes
manual review.
PAUL: So I also talked to the
Android team a little bit
about this.
I'm not sure if it's directly
related to this issue, but
I've also heard that
sometimes cellular
networks can be flaky.
Or cellular connection
can be bad.
SUDHIR: Yes.
PAUL: And that can be another
reason that this might occur,
that this error message
might occur.
SUDHIR: Definitely.
There are a lot of delays that
can happen from different
systems, yes.
MIHA: And it's more likely that
developers see this when
they test their own
application.
Because they do it with
different accounts and--
SUDHIR: Yeah.
And also they're using some of
the test systems for the
products are broken systems.
That's right.
MIHA: Great.
PAUL: So the next question that
I see is, I implemented
in-app payments in Sandbox.
It works most the time, but it
fails randomly when I test it
with different buyer accounts.
The spinning circle can go on
for more than 30 seconds
before I get the, uh-oh, there
was a problem dialogue.
You want to take
this one Miha?
MIHA: Sure.
So this can happen.
In the sandbox especially,
because you're trying
different variations
of your apps.
You try to cover all
the test cases.
And you have various
ways to debug this.
One would be the failure
callback.
On the client side you
have error codes.
You look at the error type
field in the return JSON.
And that will tell you
what happened.
Gives you an idea about
the problem.
In this case where it says it
takes more than 30 seconds,
most likely the error
type you'll get is
internal server error.
Which means something
bad happened
on the Wallet servers.
You can wait a few minutes.
Try it with a different
buyer account.
Most likely the order will
go through and you
can continue testing.
If it doesn't work again,
try switching to a
different buyer account.
If it still fails, send us
a message on the group.
We'll try to figure
out what happens.
PAUL: Yeah.
I just wanted to add that this
only occurs in Sandbox.
That in production it
does it really well.
It really occurs, if ever.
And that we are actually
working, we are aware of the
problem, the inconsistency
in Sandbox in terms
of timing and errors.
And the engineering team is
actively working on fixing
these issues.
SUDHIR: Thanks for
the question.
PAUL: The next one is, is there
a way for the seller to
get email notifications
when an order
is received or cancelled?
MIHA: Let me take this one.
So you are getting a
notification, just not an
email notification.
For successful orders, you
get two notifications.
One on the server side and
one on the client side.
And for canceled orders you
are notified on the client
side with the failure handler.
Just as I mentioned earlier, you
can look at the error type
code for an idea of
what happens.
We've been thinking about adding
email notifications.
We may do that.
They tend to be spammy.
But we can offer it as an option
for merchants who have
a low volume of orders.
If you have several hundreds
of orders per day then you
don't want to get that
many emails.
You would turn it
off immediately.
PAUL: Even if you specified your
Gmail account to receive
these emails, that would
probably start getting marked
as spam and we would just
spam block ourselves or
something like that.
I don't even know.
MIHA: So the best way to handle
it is through the
failure handlers in case of
cancellations or the server
side of success handler
in case of a success.
PAUL: Cool.
MIHA: More questions
PAUL: So let's get to
the next question.
So why doesn't Google put some
pressure on AT&T, Verizon,
other carriers, to allow Wallet
on the Galaxy S3.
It's really frustrating to not
have access to such awesome
technology because
of political BS.
This is a good question.
And so what we typically do with
our API-related products.
So we don't have a lot of
insight into Wallet, but I
went to go ask the Wallet team
anyway because I saw this
question the other day.
And their response was that we
actually do have a lot of ties
with carriers because
of Androids.
And the powers that be are
working with the carriers to
find a mutually beneficial
agreement for Wallet.
Other than that, they weren't
willing to share any
additional information
with me.
So this is what I have.
I think in the future, in a
Google payments live session
in the future, we'll bring on
somebody from the Wallet team
so that we can have a deeper Q&A
session about the future
of Wallet, its functionality,
and its features.
MIHA: Great.
So we took the question.
PAUL: Cool.
We'll go with the next one.
MIHA: The next one is a question
about availability.
I believe in a payment's
availability for other
countries for sellers.
And this is a question--
PAUL: This is actually
a new one here.
MIHA: Oh, we have a new one.
OK.
Let me answer this one and I'll
move on to the next one.
PAUL: OK.
MIHA: A question from
Carlos in Madrid.
And the good news is
in-app payments is
available in Spain.
Woo-hoo.
So Carlos is covered.
We showed you the
list earlier.
It's about 18 countries that
we offer right now.
And we plan to support
new countries.
There are slight problems.
Different countries have
different rules and
regulations for monetary
transactions.
And that slows things
a little bit.
And as we go through them and
figure out all the legal
requirements, you will see
newer countries being
added to the list.
PAUL: Cool.
MIHA: And you say there's
a new question?
PAUL: Yeah.
The new question is, Hi, is
basic authentication still
required for receiving
XML notifications?
In other words, do I still
need to use IIIS basic
authentication module?
This is a Checkout question.
So API version 2.5 I believe
is the basic API.
And in this case, instead of
us send you a notification
directly, or full notification
directly, we send a
notification to your server
indicating to you that we have
a notification awaiting
your pull.
So then you have to pull the
Checkout servers to pull the
actual notification.
And because you're requesting
it from Checkout, we're
actually using the Checkout SSL
certificate to secure the
transaction.
So in this case, no you do
not need to use basic
authentication to receive
XML notifications.
MIHA: Perfect.
One more question.
This is also Checkout
related I believe.
PAUL: Yeah.
MIHA: And the question is, it
seems difficult to understand
docs and such and programming
examples are difficult to
understand.
Is there a plan to make
them more concise?
So the question doesn't specify
what it is from, but I
know its related to the Google
Checkout API so I got a little
bit more context from
the developer.
And in this case, it relates
to level two integration of
Checkout APIs.
That is notification
and order APIs.
Level two integrations in
Checkout can be quite complex.
And its OK if you don't
understand at the beginning
and you go through a little
bit of trial and error.
I suggest as you read the
documentation, also play with
the sample library code which we
offer in the documentation
for various platforms.
And try to understand what's
going on there.
Another good resource for help
is the integration forums, the
Checkout integration forums.
And you can access
them from the
documentation page as well.
We have links there.
And if everything fails, send
us a question again.
PAUL: Cool.
I think there's one more
question left.
MIHA: Oh, we have
got one more.
We have so many live
questions.
PAUL: Keep asking.
We'll be here all day.
So the next one is, are there
any plans to have Google
Checkout be more usable on the
mobile device from a user's
perspective?
For example, on an Android
device when checking out the
user input is difficult.
It appears that there's no
mobile specific CSS or HTML.
This is a good question.
So previously we did have
a mobile specific UI.
There are a few bugs
with this UI.
Actually, there are a
few really bad bugs.
Like regardless of whichever
shipping method you chose,
only the first shipping
method would be used.
So to fix this what we're
working on or what we worked
on was changing the mobile flow
back to desktop biflow
and then trying to
update the CSS.
I don't have any more specific
details about the next steps
on the mobile flow from
the image team yet.
But what we can do is we can
reach out to the eng team for
Checkout and find out more
information about
the future of it.
MIHA: Great.
Any more questions?
PAUL: I think that is it.
MIHA: That is it.
OK.
We're almost out of time.
So thank you everyone
for watching.
Remember you can watch
the video on YouTube.
If you've been late to this
live session, the video is
available on YouTube.
PAUL: Yep.
MIHA: Every recording
it's available
there for your viewing.
And we're looking forward
to see you again
in a couple of weeks.
Send us more questions.
PAUL: And one last thing before
we go, if you want to
do something like this, if you
want to join our team, right.
And help share your knowledge
with external developers,
we're actively hiring
right now.
And to find the job list
posting, go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
And with that, I think
that's everything.
MIHA: Thank you Sudhir again for
participating in our panel
discussion.
This was helpful.
And looking forward to seeing
you again in two weeks.
Bye.
PAUL: See ya.
SUDHIR: Bye.